okay it's okay man hey what's going on
everybody's for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot one it's
the show with hot questions even hotter
winked and today I'm joined by Dax
Shepard
know from his TV show you know him from
his movies and speaking of he writes
stars and directs in the new film chips
which is set to release on March 23rd
Dax welcome to the show thank you so
much for having me I've been looking
forward to this really yep how are you
with hot food I think I'm good but it's
I bet that's the kind of person that
really goes down hard well you know what
we'll find out we're going to yeah it
will be revealed you ready to get it
going I am
[Music]
I think one that challenges me to get
through how old and cold these are than
the flight that is the classic red
carpet hot ones experienced trucks we're
filming on Saturday make them on
Thursday and let's see what happens so I
want to start by talking about chips
because your gearhead side really shines
through whether it's the patrol bike or
whether it's these crazy car scenes I
know that you're no stranger to being
behind the wheel but I have to guess
that there was a manoeuvre or a stunt of
some kind that kind of freaked you out a
little bit yeah I had to do a front end
Oh on a motorcycle right that's where
you come in you hit the front brake and
then you come do a reverse wheelie and I
had done that on a former pal motorcycle
but those police bikes away like 850 so
I crash many times in front of the crew
before I got it right which was a real
team builder for me can I felt real
quick go for it all right
what I did in preparation for this is I
drank about 70 ounces of green tea okay
I don't know if that's going to be
activities for me or help well everybody
has their own strategy to go in in so
you'll have to let me know afterwards
because we've had a lot of people try
different things and what is worse so
far it seems like nothing okay great I'm
sure I'll fall into that category myself
well I can't have you on here without
talking about Punk because we've had
several guests most notably DJ Khaled
actually think that they were getting
punked while this show really was
happening I have a DJ Khaled if I'm
saying that correctly story given to me
I need those in my face I was driving
down Santa Monica Boulevard entering
Beverly Hills and I was behind this
super interesting blue Bentley four
rolls-royce it might have been a
two-door phantom yeah yeah the famine
beam was driving eight miles an hour at
that people are flying by and I in my
head because it's Beverly Hills there's
a lot of old rich people in life when I
get past this car there's going to be
someone with an oxygen mask on her face
get up next to him his DJ found in a way
boom God knows posting what he was doing
but he was
very deep and it is means one mighty
miles an hour is that consistent with
who he is yes and all of my experiences
that definitely fits the profile okay
great I'm glad he lived up to the legend
oh I've heard you wax poetic many times
about your love for Costco do you ever
go to the food court yeah absolutely
absolutely I try to avoid that food
court but I have many times gotten those
flights of defend the hotdogs I was
going to ask about the hot dog because
the hot dog gets a lot of play does the
hot dog live up to the hype I'm a hot
dog person I'm from Detroit you know
Philly's got this the cheesesteak
Chicago's got the deep-dish pizza
Detroit's thing is Coney dogs right so
it's a natural casing hot dog with a
beautiful chili sauce on it and the bars
high right are tight for me with a hot
dog right there one thing that you kind
of get more than anything else there
artichoke dip it's just off the charts
it's such a nice product I can't speak
highly enough about that consistency and
the flavor of their artichoke dip it's
beautiful that's bland I would say
that's less hot in the previous two
that's the thing about hot sauces they
can kind of all hit you kind of
differently you know the pepper you're
right I'm getting cocky something might
bite me real bad that's not math leave a
little bit
you're the drowsier hot sauce so despite
living in a house full of women you've
made the decision to install a lazy boy
and a urinal if you were to do an
episode of cribs now as a married
hashtag dad B what would be some of the
other positive interest I will say we
have a four car garage that's completely
dedicated to horsepower so that might
shock people fans a person and valor
Prince's honor if they only let you take
two cars out of the garage to show off
which two would you pick I have a 1994
Buick Roadmaster estate wagon that's
wood crane but it also has a
supercharged v8 in it and the second one
would be my 1967 Lincoln Continental
that should go to yes which also has a
huge engine and huge brakes and all
those things and that car has been with
me for 22 years the whole ride really
I named our daughter after that would
surprise people probably more than
what's in the garages that I got away
with naming our kids after my car I
[Music]
can't imagine that I look great eating a
chicken wing so they just notice about
lighting it that my lip head look all
the way over it just couldn't be a good
technique I think I like this one so
much I'm going more bites than necessary
I love it I love it
oh [ __ ] all right the next part of
the show is a recurring segment called
explain that Graham and what we do is we
do a deep dive on our guest Instagram we
pull interesting pictures that need more
context okay I'll show you the picture
and then you just tell me the bigger
story just like that I would love to do
that all right let's top please people
like milk is that is that known to
associate the burn that's why it's out
here so it's a neutralize a little bit
right but it doesn't work it's one of
those things it's like if you're already
swimming you're swimming you know this
is a great one and what I think stands
out you put it in the caption is the
deliver deliver yeah deliver what I left
out because I love my wife but now I
feel why not tell everyone you know I
wasn't the only one that dipped in the
lovely Kristen Bell also dip whoa yeah
that is sorry Disney you look at me and
you like yet I got use tobacco and God
knows what else her you'd never see it
never in a million years does she have
like an empty gatorade bottle that she's
like spitting in it I can tell you
probably the highlight and I'm going to
I'm going to out some other people too
we did this movie love it When in Rome
that Josh Duhamel was in well it turns
out old Josh D dip - right so the three
of us on the movie dip then we went to
Italy to film and we had not brought
enough gifts so we ran out of dip and we
were panicky well Fergie was coming to
visit Josh Duhamel we said help for you
to bring a bunch of dip so she brought a
bunch of dish cuts his guess who else
dipped back man I can't speak for it now
but whoever he did forget a dip so there
was a moment where all four of us were
stand aside it's that with our spit cups
and I said now this would be a good
paparazzi photo
oh that's exciting I love blueberry they
say it's got a lot of antioxidants and
spray for thinking so a lot of
celebrities you know they rest and they
relax and places like Turks and Caicos
or the Hamptons or Palm Springs but if I
have you pegged you wouldn't want to be
anywhere but on the Michigan lakefront
code can you give me the perfect trip to
Michigan what's on the itinerary what
kind of boat do you need what are the
activities you have planned we have the
perfect trip this year was the perfect
trip we run a house on a lake we had a
kind of a smaller life which is nice
because it's nicely calm when you wake
up in the morning of your coffee out
there and the lakes are still warm in
Michigan I get up to like 85 at the end
of summer so in the morning there's
always steam coming off you drink your
coffee it's beautiful had a pontoon boat
wouldn't be my first pick but that's
what they were renting that time of year
and then just eat I eat a ton while
Americans is all this junk food I still
love for my childhood again Coney dogs
I'll have a couple hundred Coney dogs in
a week that's a great segue to the next
question and the next way you're ready
to move on - absolutely
[Music]
like I'm feeling like we're just kissing
like kissing you know I'm gonna have a
penny I wanna get not heavy petting all
right again not that shirt of yours well
this is at least second or third base
coming up okay um B apocalypse we really
cranked it up a little bit okay here we
go
[Music]
I'm really caught a conundrum here sure
sure sure sure what I don't what what's
so great about your show is seeing
people and utter pain and agony
it's so wonderful and then yet my male
pride is like I want to get through this
without any pain very fun so it's kind
of a catch-22 I want to deliver cuz I'm
an entertainer but I would just say that
sex do you you know what I mean you'd
make it whatever it is whatever you're
feeling
you don't need to put on a front for the
people there's people that we've had
they can't even get past all you can
techno there's guys that we've had to
pay [ __ ] cruise right through it you
know okay so wherever you're feeling
wherever you fall you don't need to
apologize for yeah I do I do think this
is going to [ __ ] me up though right here
just looking at the way of coagulated
and stuff and it looks like there's
chicken lips and stuff yeah what the
heck find out soon enough so food
questions do you have an opinion on the
American versus Lafayette chili dog
situation first of all I applaud you for
even knowing that is the civil war that
exists in Detroit but obvious we are a
Lafayette family and American you know
what they're damn good but I would never
ever walk into American instead of
Lafayette there's something about
Americans a little too flashy
zombie apocalypse let's talk about this
yeah all-natural zombie apocalypse sauce
it's got some scary kind of looks like
what's the holiday in Mexico the diaz de
los Muertos beautiful I could never
pronounce that
okay great so this is got kind of an
urban flyer to a little hip-hop vibe to
bomb I'm getting the reference also has
a cute little nucular reactor symbol on
so right off the bat you're feeling this
one that one's getting there
good Helens getting that good this one's
yeah this one's more present one of my
favorite things about you is that you're
very forthcoming about the infatuation
that you have with other celebrities
particularly in the category of the man
crush so one of Bounce some high profile
Dax Shepard man crushes off you and I
can kind of give me a state of there's a
lot of I have a lot to pick from and
even just one get in there by the way
yeah slower burn look at their get their
damn esterday up Tori jay-z you met him
at the meadow right you trying to get
into this circle and it didn't work out
so well if I worship any person on the
planet is jay-z it so happened that
Chris and I got seated next to him at
this big event and I was prepared to
recite every lyric he ever wrote I would
have done whatever it took Kanye West
was also at the table was not trying to
impress Kanye West I think he liked me I
think he would have wanted to hang out
with me
Beyonce was feeling it she kind of liked
it jay-z nothing I mean I guarantee if
he would saw me six seconds later after
the dinner ended and he looked at me you
wouldn't know he had dinner with and
then I know that he had a Burt Reynolds
Ryne how was it working with them should
the adage never meet your man crush be
added log had the bad experience and
I've had a good experience he was
definitely the best imaginal imaginable
from my mouth water a little bit I love
the is a show irrigating yeah here we go
nice we did this movie without a paddle
together first day on set he's in a
scene where he gets shot these
characters going to fly off a porch they
bring the stunt double anything gold
what's going on
well even mr. Reynolds we have your
double nothing he was 67 at the time he
goes to my double he's well yeah you got
to fly off the porch and then land back
there he goes
get my wetsuit what someone ran out with
a wet suit you put a wet suit on then
put on his normal wardrobe and
you just jump back like six feet at 67
years old and landed on his back
got up he's like you need another one so
this is got a lot of connotations the
other one was a bomb this one is uh want
a high-powered handgun yeah yeah long
long time off is very funny that way
yeah you know they're really trying to
get the point across that you're going
to die really quick before we bite into
it if you had to give a percentage
increase in Andy what do you think we're
going to go up right now truthfully it
all goes by the Scoville scale but I
would say that these two are the
toughest to handle in my opinion okay
and I would say this that you are on
average or you're crushing it right oh
wow they're going to be very impressed
thank you with how well - ever damn as
long as I keep the saliva in my mouth
making people you're the proud owner of
a prodigious jaws and I mean that as a
compliment of the highest honor in fact
you once said that you want your nose to
be kind of celebrated the same way that
Chuck Norrises beard was celebrated so I
want to show you some of the most
celebrated noses and popular culture and
I want to tell me if they match up to
yours if they're better if they're worse
and then maybe if you can crown a
champion I'd appreciate that and before
we look at them if I can just kind of
walk the viewer through what's going on
with my nose yeah yeah Thomas you'll
notice it's just big on its own right
and then I also was in a fist fight
where a gentleman was kind enough to
break it so it's really crooked too if
you notice while we're sitting here it
goes this way
but you need that kind of blueprint
that's what makes it so great you need
that character fingerprint where he will
he has a character nose is running a
little bit just checking with my um
symptoms but also my nostrils are just
to add to the bigness and the
crookedness my nostrils don't match
they're not homogeneous or heterogeneous
was just the worst thing an actor can
have let's see what we got bruising Owen
Wilson well he's the Bruce Lee of noses
I will say though that a DP I worked
with who had worked with Owen told me I
said hey are you being careful about how
you light this thing because it can be a
real mess he said are you kidding I just
did a movie with Owen Wilson it's like
his face threw up on itself
and I said what had quite a description
of a note but his is very sexy I think
he pulls his office really nicely what
about Alex Ovechkin
the hockey player is broken about five
times he's a hockey player but I what
I'll say about him is he still has sexy
panther like nostrils so he somehow his
nostrils have stayed symmetrical we keep
those knocks
we keep those nostrils intact you're
going to be okay mine are not intact
okay this is a very famous nose the Mona
Lisa knows I love that note I think they
call that like a Romanesque nose don't
think I find that very attractive one
women have that in fact I hate my nose
but then I see people with big crazy
noses and I kind of love it on them can
you give me a king or a queen and that
you can throw your own nose in there
who's got the greatest nose I think I've
earned his Borgnine for my money is he
it just it's like six pounds of
hamburger on face John it's so
incredible all right - Blair's Megadeth
tell me about Blair Blair is a guy from
New Jersey who's a guy of course of corn
on Blair Cyndi it's a dude from a
Minnesota it's tradition around here
that we put a little extra dab on the
last wing up you don't have to I'm gonna
want but I want to see one make sure we
do this in fact let me clear frame here
he was literally a little a little again
I can't emphasize enough how old these
wings are there's so so old that I have
as a gag had a bite out of dog biscuits
that we're about as moist Seattle now if
you go that's how the little bigger that
healthy dollop it certainly is just for
Charlie Curtis these could get so hot
that you'd be using the bones and not
even notice that's what I'm a little
nervous about because I can't beat up in
a coop ow you know I just don't want to
eat a whole bone do you I mean whatever
fur goes there goes there [ __ ] I mean
you're nervous here's a side by side
okay good
we're not go straight ones this one yeah
it's sort of a brother creeper but this
is a creeper for sure okay
how you feeling so far looks so good so
far so good
I'm actually getting now a little
concerned about my overall health I
think something might be broken in here
really like it is not yeah at a certain
point guy go hmm I have nerve damage or
something but I think price because that
was a healthy Dex bring home another
wing do we have any backup wind down do
we have any backup wings I'll show ya
take your pick oh yeah I'm going a nice
one
I do prefer thee what do we call these
those are the flat you can have my frame
without you this is a hot one first
requesting a second wing going very I'm
going into some b-ball so I'm going to
go on to Steve oka territory and then
I'm only doing although you already
you'll see chips March 24th please oh I
am I'm going to permanently destroy my
face bug and not scar my mouth that's a
lot right wait that's a lot significant
[Music]
Wow Wow
really Wow okay okay in AH in AH such a
display of machismo olives
I cannot even even be in the room I'm
not I'm so how did it I air my chest to
be here I'm so happy that I've impressed
you because I really wanted to do you
have I'm floored I'm spared a fentanyl
patch on my back you might have
introduced me to my new career I know I
I feel like my seats a little bit hot
right now I mean it's starting to
definitely percolate mm-hmm mm-hmm
I got a real coating of it yeah you did
I think you're paying it right for sure
we did
that's a perfect place to be now that
we're sizzling now that the brains
moving because I know that you are in
the math club and junior high you credit
that experience for building your
self-confidence yeah and kind of making
you into the man that you are today so
now that your brain is flooded with
Blair's Megadeath sauce with liquid rage
perhaps the most Blair's Megadeath sauce
with liquid rage you have ever had on
our wing pen finale
yeah I want to hit you start to get
along with some hot sauce math word
problems I have some scratch paper for
you I do have a pen
I think that you're good to get two out
of three of these right don't you run
the board on this little helmet oh my
nose on the cloth do whatever you have
to do oh yeah there's a lot of snot I've
got to let it go I mean that was in
Detroit opened up that way in sync all
right you ready blares Megadeth's off
measures a heat of 550,000 Scoville
units which is a hundred and ten times
hotter than a smoked jalapeno where does
a jalapeno measure on the Scoville scale
okay that's easy it seems we're going to
knock that off we're going to knock that
up so then we're doing I don't in a 55
for that's 45 so 5,000 times hotter
ding-ding-ding is one for one he's one
for one all right Arthur orders three
dozen lemon pepper wings which is 14
lemon pepper wings more than Ellen how
many lemon pepper wings did Ellen order
girl it was 14 more than she had 22 she
had 20 doing honey too late I didn't
even have to do the thing look at you
you're so good whoo one more maybe kind
of do about the paper if you look at you
yeah
so I'm ordering three hot sauces online
sriracha for five dollars Tabasco for
$5.99 and dabomb for seven dollars
even if shipping cost 350 total and
there's no tax what's my total cost so
2340 92140 92142 NT for it's okay dad
down okay okay okay it's okay yeah man
like that's awesome but there's nothing
to be ashamed of today - you made it
through some were whispering extra wing
you got two out of three math questions
right just camera that camera or that
camera let the people know what you have
going on here like guys please March
24th go check out chip if you like bad
boys if you like leave the webinar if
you love action comedy with a ton action
I'm really perverted comedy it's for you
women you'll like it even more than you
would think you'd like it because
there's a love story at the heart of it
so 5 & 5 that's 1099 oh that's where I
thought that's 1099 yep that's $17.99
that's 24 yeah yep well Jess you can
check the map you can check the mess -
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you like the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend